ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi sono
orgoglioso di tornare il suo amico
andrea beccari fortunati di oggi vediamo
che cosa succede
le scotte perché secondo me è abbastanza
ciao
allora io ho notato una roba ho notato
una cosa che mi fa vedere subito che la
maglia fanno ecco la felpa alberto sordi
ma e siamo siamo entrambi targati gucci
ragazzi senza senza parole non sorrideva
e mi piace sta sta non ho più quel mondo
di capelli
io vorrei quelli già non ha voluto non è
venuto fa il che va benissimo perché
sono verità no no no no aspetta lo
scherzo è bene avere vai vai col panico
c'è un bel altro bacino
aspetta aspetta cielo sotto
quest'aspetto aspettavo incendio allora
spetta famiglia della maglia fame della
felpa con il aspetta aspetta se mi dai
vip non capisco e ariana grande l'anno
stampata al contrario non la dovevi
comprare le gambe ai partiti hanno
sbagliato a stamparlo e vabbè stai
facendo che stai facendo niente realtà
che ti cercavo e non avrei mai pensato
ok
neanche io rimetto e saperi contrari
alla grande meglio però sono sono cose
che anzi guarda aspetta adesso siamo
pari
l'indirizzo all'indirizzo a meritiamo
eccellenti ti ringrazio tesoro come ti
chiami che non sono parsi ansia come la
finanza marina come la fidanzata di
finita tra profit dai grande partita sei
l'unica italiana che mi supera di
scrivere ma fammi una foto come si deve
lo hai fatto da marziano che cercano
certi che per me bacio anche io ti
voglio bene ciao roma è possibile 4 ore
e cerco di non voto come lo ascolto
quali lo vogliono
scatta io voglio vedere da queste foto
che finiscono perché me l'hanno fatta e
giorgio il numero di narco di tango
grazie veramente ne ho bisogno per
sentirmi nuovo migliore veramente
infarti a parte piacere lorenzo sai come
piacere le arche che c'era dentro
eoliche certo c'è un solo partito alle
22 per cercati mammamia mio grazie non
so che dirti di dove sei dove sei gare
un giocatore che userete catania di
catania 6 di catania catanese abbiamo un
sacco di amici che vengono dalla e mi
piace un sacco di vorrei veramente
benissimo ma sta registrando zona certo
con gli occhiali allora feci metto io
non ce li ho pesca
come perché amano bannato domigo ma per
cosa ho fatto
ma come perché niente riavvia il modo
prova a vedere se funziona per aggirare
il ban
hai delle belle cuffie se hai voglia di
portarmi le penso che le mie non siano
livello mi chiamo lorenzo piacere le
presentazioni a fare il giro perfetto ci
vediamo la prossima cosa studi di
giurisprudenza no porca la medicina
informatici ti capisco
ti capisco anche se io studiavo solo il
primo scaffale che vedo lì questo è il
mio padre
ah ok e alberto angela e va bene troppa
cultura nella mia vita questa cosa e
come la figura grazie a questa è la
reaction che ci piace questa reaction
che ci piace allora dietro vedo un po di
lewis lo vedo in alto a destra sembra
sembra veramente luiz sono vuote sotto
ci sono i voti a sinistra c'è
roma grande di zero come la tua essere
ma non ho capito niente
ok non mai rapporti per favore ti
premiamo necessità di vederla volevo
vedere un ritaglio grazie me lo metti
davanti per favore che vorrei parla con
lui in un coltello grazie io ignoro dove
tu abbia preso questa cosa ma non lo
voglio neanche sapere da 0 a 6 anni so
che devo fare è finita li ha ritirati
alle d'opera con lui caro amico mio che
mi seguì lo so vivendo un po sciupato è
veloce qualcosa in nome però sono
contento della gente così allegra che vi
segue presenta dirmi oggi questo video è
molto kringe ma la mia voglio avere
conosciuta non sei del nord a sé il
video di dialetti che voleva restare una
foto certo figurati ci mancherebbe ma
latina foto gusto calzino vorrei dirti
perché ce l'ho ma ci ho ripensato
mi piace l'accento calabrese si sente
tantissimo
cioè se tipo mi chiamo marcena non
sorprende anche farlo
il piccolissimo è difficilissimo farlo
ciao amico sei dentro un armadio che mi
consigli da vestire qualcosa la barra
tempo di fujita bravo lui c è meglio
solo che io sono un po se c'è un
braccino un cortissimo quindi vado di fa
vj capito a chip ma che fa lo stesso
effetto insomma rimorchi stretta di mano
virtual pa grande botto
certo certo fine penso acqua e
bellissimo rifarlo la white harte ciao
amico mio caldarella gesù cristo
stai calma calma calma temere come ti
chiami anzitutto arianna arianna piacere
anno sono lorenzo cosa che fai aria
nella vita studi per me si sono
all'ultimo anno ce l'ho fatta io quindi
va it easy veramente i visi stai
tranquilla grazie dell'infarto sono
molto contento di questo in diretta ma
possiamo fare la faccia
certo che possiamo fare la foto
figurativa bene mi stai pulendo sto
pulendo la webcam mimini vedi tipo
strano non solo se sì ti vedo e non o
quello so io dico a me sinceramente di
te non mi interessa nulla
va bene voglio è lui che ti word o caro
mio
poi si chiamano questa bestiolina lui si
chiama chicco con tutte cup mazza non in
codice questo è stato il batti cinque ma
ero bella zio dell'addio gatto che un pò
strano però va bene va bene ragazzi
questo era tutto però mi call di oggi
volevo concludere dicendo vi due cose
allora innanzitutto che se non siete
riuscite incontrarmi in tranquilli
perché un vicolo intenzione di farlo tra
pochissimo perché lo voglio inserire nei
blog voglio inserire nei blog uno mi gol
speciale dove ognuno mi fa una domanda è
quindi rispondo alle domande in diretta
vi chiedo scusa ragazzi se è un unico lo
un pochettino più tranquillo del solito
perché comunque hanno registrato che era
molto tardi di notte
io ringrazio tutti i partecipanti
ringrazio tutti voi che avete visto
questo video
spero che vi sia piaciuto e come al
solito ragazzi 6 vi è piaciuto lasciato
momento mi piace anche per il sociale
come da tradizione e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]